what if I told you that the film the
Marvels is actually going to fix a big
problem a lot of fans have had with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe lately and no
I'm not kidding to my surprise I have
actually seen a lot of hype for the
Marvels AKA Captain Marvel 2 which comes
as a pleasant surprise because a lot of
people do really like to dog on the
first Captain Marvel film in which I
even have to say myself I wasn't the
biggest fan of however I will say that
the Marvel does truly look like a it's
going to be a great movie but here's the
kicker regardless of how the movie does
regardless of whether it is good or it
is bad it's going to fix a problem that
a lot of fans have had with the MCU
lately and it's going to do it in a
pretty big way and that is connectivity
or rather I should say big connectivity
because we have had connectivity in the
MCU it's just not on a very large scale
take Miss Marvel for example it
connected to Captain Marvel she is a
Captain Marvel Super Fan they went to to
Avengers con it connected to the overall
MCU we just didn't at the time see that
it had any really huge impact the same
thing goes for w division it connected
to Multiverse of Madness it set the
whole thing up but what fans have been
missing is that connectivity to the
overall huge threat that a big bad would
have for a saga and not to mention phase
4 opened with huge multiversal
implications with Loki and that hasn't
really been addressed too much except
for Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness in which it didn't even
reference the events of Loki they just
simply mentioned incursions and they
jumped across the Multiverse a little
bit however the Marvel's is going to
connect and it's going to set up a lot
moving forward in the MCU in fact this
is going to directly connect to Avengers
King Dynasty so let's talk about how
this could fix that big connectivity
problem that Marvel Studios seems to be
having right now but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos also if
you subscribe and leave leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month what's actually kind of
crazy is that if you think about it
Marvel right now with phase four five
and six are kind of doing what they did
with Phase 1 2 and three in the infinity
Saga we weren't introduced to Thanos
until the post credit scene for the
first Avengers film from there it was
another 2 years until we saw Thanos
again in the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie and then we didn't see him
again until the next Avengers film Age
of Ultron and this is kind of where
everything started to come together for
the infinity stone concept and the
reveal that Thanos had The Infinity
Gauntlet and was actively searching for
them now Marvel Studios right now isn't
that far off they introduced he who
remains in Loki in phase four the first
phase of this new saga but he wasn't
teased as such a big bad yet he was
teased that he could potentially be a
huge threat but since he let Loki and
Sylvie kill him and talked about how
dangerous his variants were more
dangerous than him more evil than him he
himself didn't seem like such a big bad
at the time despite his warning of what
would happen if they killed him so that
was our first tease of our big bad in
the first phase of this new Saga now
we're only a little bit into phase five
but we've already had our big bad teas
in Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
then we're going to get Loki season 2
and Loki season 2 is different because
we now know how big of a threat Kang is
thanks to Loki season 1 and Ant-Man
Quantum Mania so here is where our big
bad comes into play in a really big way
so if you think about it that way this
Saga is kind of on par with the infinity
Saga like I mentioned the only issue
that we've run into is nothing else
really seems connected to the bigger
picture which is Kang and his variants
wanting to take control over the
Multiverse and causing incursions the
problem is Everything feels pretty
separated Multiverse of Madness explored
the Multiverse but really wasn't
connected to Loki Loki in introduced he
who remains and talked about these evil
variants but Ant-Man and the was quantum
Mania didn't seem connected to Loki at
all besides the fact that it was the
same actor playing a version of Kang in
theory this should change with the
Marvels based on new information that we
have learned about the movie the first
thing that we've learned that is
actually quite huge is that there's
going to be an incursion in the Marvels
or at least the start of one with our
main Universe at that if what we have
recently heard from some insiders is
true Monaro in the trailer for the
Marvels will be investigating an
incursion so at the beginning of the
teaser trailer where Monica Rambo goes
up to some type of a wall that is in
space it looks to be some type of energy
wall or a hex gate well this is actually
an incursion wall according to The
Insider cryptic HD quality this is what
we will see happen in the Marvels a hole
is ripped in space and time and a
different reality starts seeping into
the world this is an incursion and
apparently this is when we are first
going to see two realities start to fuse
together and this is huge this is going
to be one of the things that makes the
MCU finally feel like everything is
coming together since Loki the
Multiverse has been teased and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
showed us that incursions can happen but
we have yet to experience any of that in
our personal Universe speaking of the
616 universe but that is all apparently
about to change if what we are hearing
is true and we have good reason to
believe it's true because producers for
the Marvels have even come out and
teased us a little bit on what exactly
is going to happen in the Marvels and
how it sets up King Dynasty and Secret
Wars well first and foremost the
director Nia dasta said you'll get
enough of the story of how and why
darbin has acquired the Bengal then one
of The Producers for the Marvels Mary
leano said this in Miss Marvel we
learned that the Bengal paired with some
other form of power can force a
temporary hole in space and time to lead
to somewhere else with the power of of
both Bengals more is definitely possible
and we see the culmination of that over
the course of this movie it definitely
leads to plentiful opportunities for the
future of the MCU whatever the Avengers
and Secret Wars teams may want to do
with them so it seems like they are
severely hinting that these two Bengals
when used together can open a rift in
space and time and that can lead to
Jumping to another universe and this
makes sense because it truly does seem
like the Bengals are Kang technology and
if that is true true Kang has probably
used these to jump through space and
time so that's another huge connection
that is going to happen in the Marvels
we will start to kind of learn how Kang
is able to do what he does plus not to
mention the Bengals are connected to the
10 Rings we found that out during the
Marvel so this will connect back to
shangi as well and of course obviously
it's connecting to Miss Marvel so not
only is the Marvels connecting to a lot
of previous projects that we've already
seen but it's going to connect to a lot
of future projects and it's going to
directly set up Avengers King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars according to
the producers of the movie and last but
not least take this with a grain of salt
but we've heard a rumor that Kang or at
least his eyes are going to be appearing
in one of the post-credit scenes for the
Marvels this is unconfirmed at the time
so take it with a grain of salt but if
this is true then the Marvels will even
further connect everything past present
and future of the MCU together so I know
a lot of people weren't really expecting
the Marvels to be that huge of a movie
but based off of everything that we've
heard so far it is indeed going to be
huge and have serious implications for
the future of the MCU die for one I'm
personally really excited to start to
see all of the Kang connections finally
come together and to finally see an
incursion start to happen in our
universe that's one of the biggest
things that makes this movie so
important the arrival of an actual
incursion because that sets up Secret
Wars so this is where it's about to feel
super real where will'll start to feel
the Pres presence of King the Conqueror
being the big bad and the presence of
the King Dynasty and Secret Wars coming
right around the corner so hopefully
this takes Marvel fans excitement to a
completely new level after this movie
comes out and hopefully it's going to be
a really great movie but if what we're
hearing is true this should fix that
Marvel connectivity problem that people
have been complaining about we shouldn't
feel like things aren't connecting after
this film this should bring it all
together and Marvel has a lot of really
awesome projects planned for after the
Marvels so perhaps This truly will be
the film that makes the MCU kind of turn
around in its current point that
combined with Marvel studios's new plan
to make Disney Plus shows kind of feel
like these big events it seems like the
MCU really is about to take a big turn
for the better and moving forward since
there is an incursion happening in the
MCU we can expect other projects to
possibly address this and connect to
King Dynasty and Secret Wars as well so
hold on to your hope and get excited for
the future of the the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Kang Dynasty and secret War
should be absolutely insane and
everything that is going to happen in
between and even before but go ahead and
let us know your thoughts about this in
the comments down below if this all
happens if it's all starting to get
connected do you think this will fix
that kind of empty hole in people's
stomachs that people have been feeling
due to the lack of connectivity in the
MCU will it be resolved if everything
that has been rumored to happen actually
happens in this movie go ahead and let
us know all of your thoughts about this
in the comments down below and of course
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest MCU news don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
woof